Oh, my God.
[inaudible].
Twinkle twinkle little star. How I wonder what you, but wait a minute.
Why are you twinkling so much? Whoa guys,
that's no diamond in the sky that looks like a supernova.
As much as we love to blow stuff up here on earth,
no bombs or pyrotechnics could compare to the incredible force
of nature's biggest explosion.
The supernova as a star reaches its grand
finale and explodes. What would happen to life on earth?
If we were close by how far away from a
supernova are we considered safe?
Could anything survive?
It's deadly radiation and what makes super
Novi valuable to us?
This is what if, and here's what would happen.
If a supernova exploded close to earth
before you freak out earth is in a relatively safe patch of space
called the local bubble.
This peanut shaped region of expanding gas in our Milky way.
Galaxy results from nearby supernova explosions that occurred
20 million years ago.
These explosions helped shape our solar system, spreading gas,
Dustin heavier elements like uranium and gold to earth
without the super Novi.
We wouldn't have any shiny gold bling or powerful nuclear reactors.
So you can literally count your lucky stars. Okay,
but are we in danger of any nearby supernova?
On average,
a supernova will occur about once every 50 years in the Milky way.
Thankfully, there are no stars,
massive enough to become a supernova within 50 light years of the earth.
There is however one binary star system within
159 light years of earth that could potentially put us at
risk binary star systems are type one
supernova.
This happens in a tumultuous dance between two stars where matter
is sucked from one star into another, typically a white dwarf.
Eventually the white dwarf explodes resulting in an Epic
supernova.
On the other hand type two supernova occur when a star runs out of
fuel and some of its mass flows into its core over time,
the core will start to grow and get so heavy that it can't withstand its
gravitational force and blue.
The core collapses and a supernova is born.
When these explosions occur,
a powerful blast of radiation is spread throughout space.
That will kill anything within 50 light years to
put this in perspective how our solar system is only about
two light years wide.
So the supernovas blast would be the distance of
25 of our solar systems in a row.
If a supernova occurred as close as 30 light years away,
we'd have bigger problems than a pandemic on our hands.
The intense blast of radiation would carry a massive influx of
high energy neutrinos that would boil any living creature from the
inside out. Hope you like your meals poached.
The entire earth could be vaporized in just a fraction of a second.
If the supernova was close enough,
the shockwave would arrive with enough force to wipe out our entire
atmosphere. And even our oceans,
the exploded star would grow brighter for about three weeks after the explosion
casting shadows, even during the day,
even if life survived,
the superheated gas from the supernova would emit deadly amounts of
UV and gamma radiation.
These rays would destroy the ozone layer leading to the formation of
nitrous oxide, smog. We would all have to go deep,
underground and embrace our new lives.
As mole people do escape the lethal radiation, poisonous atmosphere.
Unfortunately there would be an increase in mutations and deadly
cancers.
And to top it all off our phytoplankton,
which account for almost 50% of all photosynthetic activity on
earth would die off.
Phytoplankton is vital to us and can absorb carbon dioxide from our
atmosphere without it we'd have a tougher time breathing
global warming would accelerate even further beyond our control
and as an essential food source at the bottom of the Marine food chain,
a lack of phytoplankton would result in secret years becoming extinct
and eventually humankind would too.
So like many what ifs, almost everything dies,
but there might still be a few lucky speeds seize up extreme of files
that can survive the intense radiation.
After a few hundred or thousands of years,
the supernova would leave an impressive Nebula in its wake.
At the very least we'd have a fantastic view in our night sky. Well,
for those of us that can see maybe these extreme of
files would evolve to have eyes someday and become the size of humans.
Well, whatever might happen, that's a story for another.
What if.